hello i'm bruno cavallar i'm a phd
student at university of oreck and today
i'll be talking about algorithms and
lower bounds for comparator circuits
from shrinkage
this is joint work with jean gendu
who is also a postdoc here at the
university of foreign
so in computational complexity we are
interested in understanding the
intrinsic complexity of computational
problems we want to know we want to know
how much computational resources a
computational task requires to be solved
and one of the main
computational tasks we are interested in
is the task of is our decision problems
which are problems in the following form
you receive an input and you want to
know if it satisfies or does not satisfy
a given property
and one way of modeling decision
problems is by means of boolean
functions which are functions that
receive a binary string as an input and
output either zero or one
and one way of studying the complexity
of boolean functions is by means of
circuits
so as you're seeing this as as you seen
this in this picture a circuit is a
directional cyclic graph
in which the sources are labeled with
inputs
and the other vertices are labeled with
the logical operations and they're
called gates
and one of the gates is singled out to
be the output gate the the the
the vertex the the only vertex that is a
sink in the in the direction a cyclic
graph
and the question we ask in circuit
complexity is
what is the size of the smallest circuit
that computes a function f
okay note that this is a complete model
of computation in the sense that every
algorithm can efficiently be represented
by a circuit
this is a
well-known fact in computational
complexity which implies that lower
bounds for circuits
also imply in the inexistence of
algorithms
okay
so uh the well-known problem of p
version p is basically about in
existence of polynomial time algorithms
for the complexity class and p
so to separate p first from np
taking the information from the previous
slide it means that it suffices to show
super polynomial or bounds on the side
of circuits computing a function in np
however proving circular bounce in
general has proved to be very hard
indeed a superlinear bounce for
circuits uh is still an open problem
the bachelor bound we have for general
circuits is of the rotor 5n
this strongly motivates the study of
restricted circuit classes in which we
hope we might be more successful and we
also might improve our proof techniques
the circuit the restricted circuit model
we're going to be
restricting ourselves in this talk is
the
model of comparator circuits
so comparator circuits are basically um
just boolean circuits that only contain
comparator gates
so what's a comparator gate so each gate
has exactly fan out too so um basically
the restriction where we're putting on
the on the boolean circuit is that
you're having bounded fan out
and uh
um
one of the wires of the gate will
compute the ore of the incoming bits and
the other wire will compute the end of
the incoming bits
okay
and we can consider the negations to be
all at the bottom not the literals
an equivalent representation of
comparative circuits is by means of this
drawing as a set of horizontal lines
which are which we call wires
and they are labeled with literals
okay
and
each gate in this representation is
basically an ordered pair of wires
which is represented as an arrow in this
drawing at the tip of the arrow is the
or gate and the bottom of the arrow is
the and gate
in this particular figure comparators we
can see a comparator circuit with two
inputs four wires and four gates and we
in which the third wire computes the
parity of the two bits
okay
so what can comparative circuits do as a
local notation for this slide we'll
denote cc
to be the class of polynomial size
comparator circuits and cc brackets as
um the class of problems solved by size
s comparator circuits and of course the
size of comp of a comparator circuit is
the number of comparator gates okay
so simulations um
um it's easy to see that formulas of
size s can be simulated by comparator
circuits of size s right formulas are
basically
are exactly
circuits with fan out exactly one so
it's not hard to see that they can be
simulated by comparative circuits
however there is already a fine grain
fine-grain disparity between these two
models
in the sense that
just by
building the construction of the
previous slide we see that we can
compute parity with linear size
comparator circuits
whereas it's well known that parity
requires quadratic size formulas
it is it has it has also been proved in
the past that non-deterministic
branching programs can be simulated by
comparator circuits with only a
polynomial overhead
and these two simulations that give us
as a consequence that the complexity
class of nc1 which is contained in an nl
uh both of them are contained in the
class cc
uh so it would be a
big question
how's the what is the relationship
between cc and nc
uh and it and their conjecture should be
incomparable so nc which is
the class of polylog time parallel
computation
this is
conjecture to be comparable to nc
and for the following reasons uh so
first uh stable marriage
is a problem that can be solved by
comparative circuits
but uh
we don't expect it it should be in nc
because
all the algorithms we know for stable
marriage are inherently sequential
this conjecture of incomparability is
also supported by oracle separations
there were recently approved by cook
filmos and lee in 2014
and uh also by
a recent
work of robert pitassi roseman cook in
2016-16
who show that there exists a function in
monotone and c2 which cannot be computed
by monotone comparator circuits okay so
there is a
separation
uh
in the monotone world
with regards to majority it's an open
question so
we know that comparator circuits
can compute majority with linear linear
number of wires and n log n gates this
is a result of i thai kamlos and zametti
in 1983 but it's still unknown whether
majority can be computed by comparator
circuits
of linear size can we prove a
superlineal rebound for majority
for comparator circuits are
are
are
are these a linear number of gates
enough for computing majority with
comparative circuits
okay
so lower balance for comparator circuits
uh
so the first mono tumbler bound for
comparative circuits were approved 2016
by on the previous mesh previously
mentioned paper of robert petalsi
roseman cook they approved an
exponential rebound
for monotone comparator circuits
however the first airbound for
non-monotonic comparator circuits were
shown uh also only in 2019 by gallon
robert is
over 30 years
after over 30 years of study of this
class is the first uh
berliner bound
for this class
and they showed um
a n over login to the 1.5 worst case
they're bound for some functions
deriving p
they're they're
they're the lower bound basically it
adapts a technique of nature perk from
1966
and with a new structural result about a
comparative circuit study
exhibited
okay
so what are our results for comparator
circuits so first we prove uh we proved
the first average cases were bound for
comparator circuits which match governor
bears worst case rebound and we also
show the first circuit analysis
algorithms for comparator circuits
circuit analysis algorithms are a
crucial step for understanding a circuit
class and they are well known
for many of
the most well studied
classes such as ac0 acc demorgan
formulas branching programs etc
in our work we give counting side
algorithms pseudo-random generators and
learning algorithms for
compressor circuits
so first let's talk about the average
case verbal
so average case complexity uh
is a definition of cryptography the
existence of one-way functions is
predicated on
on average keys on the existence of
average case hard problems
and it's also maybe a proxy uh for
talking about
complexity
in the context of more realistic inputs
so the theorem we show is that for every
k where k is at least log n
uh there is there exists a polynomial
time computable function f
f depending on k
and
which has n bits such that for every
comparator circuit c with at most
uh entity 1.5 gates
the circuit will
agree with f
in at most one half plus
a factor that decreases exponentially k
inputs
okay
and this
this can be seen to match governor
bear's lower bound when we let k to be
big o of log n
and that and the decreasing
factor there
in the
correlation
will be
polynomial in n
okay
so
our next
next result is a satisfiability
algorithm for comparator circuits
so the set problem is it's known to be
np-complete it's conjecture not to have
exponential time algorithms but i still
can ask the question
what about slightly known trivia
algorithms can we do anything better
than
just brute force through all through all
um
all inputs
this is this is a
question that is intrinsically
interesting i think
but um for the purpose of circling black
seed it was it was shown to be even more
interesting by
ryan williams and who's
who is uh shown that um
that how non-trivial satisfiability
algorithms can often be used to prove
circular bounds for the same
circuit circuit class
okay
so our theorem we show that there is an
algorithm that counts the number of
satisfy assignments of a given
comparator circuit
with at most entity 1.5 gates
taking time
that is a non-trival
okay and those numbers there are easily
seen to be non-trivial
when k is little omega of log n
uh
the runtime becomes to the n over a
super polynomial factor
our second algorithm is a pseudo rhino
generator
so a serial number generator is a
deterministic efficient procedure whose
output looks random over uniformly
random inputs for a given circuit class
in other words the output is
indistinguishable from a random input
for a certain class in a way it it
exhibits a fundamental weakness of that
circuit class
and it's closely related to
general randomization and cryptography
so our theorem we show that there is a
serial remainder generator opposite
length s to the n over two over three
uh that fall falls comparator circuits
with s gates
okay
so basically if if on the comparator
circuit has size at most
uh
enter the 1.5
then there's a certain
generator that fools
this comparator circuit
um
using
established and known techniques
this can be be used to prove
uh entity 1.5 lower bound for mcsp
against comparator circuits
and
so mcsp is uh is
is the minimal circuit size problem it's
a problem which
of deciding where a given truth table of
a function whether it can be computed by
a small circuit or not
and uh in a risk and if this is a very
important
problem in computational complexity in
itself but a recent line of work called
harness magnification has intensified
his interest by showing that weak
circular bounds for variants of mcsp
also imply complexity breakthroughs
okay
yeah so
so we can use our serum generator to
also prove uh our bond frame csp against
comparator circuits
so what are our techniques
uh we use a established well-established
technique called shrinkage
under one of the restrictions we show
that if you randomly fix a fraction p of
the values of some variables the size of
the circuit shrinks by a vector p to the
gamma for some gamma and we do it we
show that it happens with high
probability
and gamma is also known as the shrinkage
exponent
and
shrinkage can be used to show average
case lower bounds and serum generators
and in our work we show how shrinkage
can be used also to analyze comparative
circuits and we give a more detailed
analysis to give the matching lower
bounds for instance
so
so the question is how can we apply
shrinkage for comparator circuits
uh if you think of that drawing when you
set the value of a wire we can only
eliminate one gate
right in the worst case maybe if that
wire is connected to only one gate
it's not clear how to apply apply the
shrinkage technique here
however a structural result of gold and
repair
show that whenever a comparator circuit
has l wires
there is also an equivalent comparator
circuit with l wires and i'll choose two
gates
this means that if we shrink the number
of wires in the restriction we also
indirectly
shrink the number of gates so instead of
trying to approve directly
a shrinkage for gates we previous
shrinkage for wires
okay and this gives us a shrinkage on
the sides of the circuit in general
we also prove
we also
describe data structure for implementing
galvan repairs conversion
in other words
given a comparative circuit with l wires
this data structure helps to find
another equivalent comparator circuit
with l wires and let's use two gates
efficiently
and this this is used in in
in our satisfiability algorithm where we
store
the number of satisfying assignments of
of
all restricted circuits
so open problems uh
can we improve the analysis from entity
1.5 to n to the 1.51 this would of
course be implied by a better shrinkage
result result where gamma is at least
one over two
so is this lower bound the best possible
with current techniques or can we push
the boundary further
this is
strongly connected to hardness
magnification so can we show that entry
1.51 lower bounds for comparator
circuits for some specific functions
like mcsp have major consequences in
complexity theory
we can show that enter date 2.01 is
enough but this is far from the best
lower bounds we know
and finally
a question that i'm personally more
interested is
this and the question about the
approximation method so the largest um
restricted circuit class
that under the approximation matter of
rasmurov is capable of
capturing is the class of
non-deterministic branching programs
which are simulated by comparator
circuits so my question
so would be interested in knowing
whether
the approximation can also be
used to study comparator circuits and
perhaps even be used to prove
lower bound for majority in this model
thank you